I think we're getting Great Looks I  think um but it also could be teams  giving us Great Looks I mean if you  'd be completely honest we're not a team  that's constructed of great shooting and  that's just the truth of the matter is  it's not like you know we're sitting  here with a lot of lasers on our team so  you know but that doesn't deter us from  still trying to get great shots when we  get those opportunities you take them  but we're not sitting here with a bunch  of 40 plus career three-point shooting  guys coming in just look like a football  team you know if like you know if you  had a football analogy and you had a  bunch of guys that was underneath route  Runners and you're wondering why the  quarterback is not throwing 20 plus uh  you know passes down the field okay you  know that's that's how the team was  constructed so  you can't win Brady did it